[Música]
i
y
eeuu con una población de más de 328
millones de personas es el país que más
recursos naturales de la tierra consume
los resultados de un estudio de la
organización ecologista global footprint
network revela que el país
norteamericano necesitaría 5 planetas
como este para subsistir en los últimos
años con el gobierno de donald trump no
se había impulsado ninguna política
medioambiental incluso se había
desligado del acuerdo de parís de hecho
la situación era límite ya que la
intención era incluso repotenciar la
industria de los combustibles fósiles
sólo en 2018 las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono en eeuu aumentaron hasta un 3,4
por ciento lo que representa el mayor
nivel en ocho años pero la nueva
administración con el presidente joe
biden mucho más comprometido con la
crisis climática quiere que eeuu juega
un papel importante en la lucha contra
el cambio climático entre sus planes
está la reducción de emisiones de
petróleo gas y carbón además de impulsar
nuevas industrias de producción de
energías limpias que no sólo
beneficiaría al medio ambiente sino
también a la economía del país básica
porque crearía nuevos puestos de trabajo
[Música]
australia es uno de los países que más
recursos naturales consumen se
necesitarían 4.6 planetas tierra para
que toda la población mundial viviera
como un australiano además tiene la
cuarta huella ecológica más grande del
mundo debido a las emisiones de carbono
ya la gran cantidad de tierra requerida
para cultivos y pastoreo australia es
uno de los mayores exportadores de
combustibles fósiles del mundo y en el
último ranking de la onu que mide el
progreso de 193 países en metas de
sostenibilidad australia ocupó el último
lugar sin embargo hoy en día el 30% de
la energía de australia es renovable y
se espera que muy pronto llegue al 50%
el gobierno federal ha creado un fondo
de 3 mil 500 millones de dólares
australianos para cumplir los
compromisos del acuerdo de parís uno de
ellos es reducir en al menos 26 por
ciento las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero para el año 2030 los
ambientalistas le piden al gobierno
federal que haga más esfuerzos para
salvar el planeta
[Música]
el día del sobregiro ecológico es el día
en el que se agotan los recursos que la
tierra puede regenerar durante el año y
cada vez ese día llega más pronto en
rusia desde los tres países que más
recursos consumen si todo el mundo
vivirá como un ruso promedio se
necesitarían 34 planetas la principal
asignatura pendiente' de los rusos es el
reciclaje rusia todavía no tiene una
tradición de reciclaje de separación de
desechos y mientras tanto los vertederos
de basura actualmente existentes están
alcanzando cada vez más sus límites de
capacidad según una auditoría del
gobierno ruso sólo un 7% de los residuos
se reciclan en rusia cada año el total
de área de vertederos crecen 400.000
hectáreas y el año pasado ascendía ya a
4 millones de hectáreas más o menos el
tamaño de los países bajos estas cifras
están entre las más grandes del norte
del planeta y apuntan según los expertos
a un patrón de reciclaje muy deficiente
por parte de los rusos
[Música]